oh là là qu'on met pas de bouquet mais
s'il est un homme ça vous fera peut-être
plaisir c'est le seul ce que j'ai réussi
à mieux y a pas trouvé plus grands noms
mais bien dans ma vie à la hauteur du
talent je suis désolé maintenant je vais
la garder une veste peinte par jamel
debbouze up allait se classe elle l'a
une veste fin par jamel debbouze qui
devait tu devais être ridicule à
l'ancienne je sais pas j'ai questionné
ce qu'elle en pense on en dit on audirac
toujours oui c'est une vieille tradition
les airs et là tu dirais ça c'est bien
on à la télévision
les ingénieurs à ce que je propose c'est
comment cette petite pause on écoute
libre de michèle laroque choisi
spécialement pour elle
oui c'est livre de michèle laroque et la
blessure
elle est vêtue pense que tu arrives à
plat chaud
la musique aussi
si beaucoup âgés 12 ou bien est-ce que
ça vous voulez qu'on le garde un montage
du nord je n'ai jamais regardé ça aussi
écoute bien bien
/
il ya d'abord les vaisseaux
je
j
j'essaie russie
comme tu le sens
c'est ça aussi
et voilà alors ce n'est toi tu le sais
mais maria vous savez que jamel remonte
sur scène et la cei c'est un événement
quoi oui c'est toujours un évènement
effectivement quand est-ce que tu
remontes alors du 13e décembre au 18
décembre au casino de paris
ensuite jean celle du vin fin j'ai pas
l'exacte et date exacte mais c'est
casino de paris bataclan olympiens vous
êtes allé parce que j'ai raté la
première fois que je ferai les mêmes
jeunes au village jamais 100% debbouze
donc je voulais profiter de cette
émission pour pro pour pour faire une
petite annonce mais lille peut venir de
seconde
ah oui alors c'est méline stavel milices
et l'autre comme ça et ville sicilienne
sont vraiment ces mélina wedin mellila
l'artiste luxin c'est une basket que je
signais moi-même l'asse écrit jamel
debbouze
ouais avec mark en arabe ici espoir et
c'est celle acquise à dessiner oui c'est
une basket qu'on que des styles et les
bénéfices de cette basket sont destinés
à aider les enfants des rues au maroc
par le biais de l'association l'heure
joyeuse et plus en vendre plus on en
vendra plus on aidera des gosses qui
sont défavorisés pas seulement au maroc
mais même un peu partout dans le monde
et je voulais faire un peu la publicité
de cette basket bon bien sûr elle
s'appelle jamel debbouze elle est
extraordinaire et elle comme elle
déchire sa mère cette carte propose
exactement la même là
non c'est juste pour tester le show pour
dire qu'elle est en vente bientôt
acheter
m
oui les arabes
jamel debbouze je vais crier d'y aller
parce que j'ai des courses à faire ouais
c'est que c'est vraiment dans ce drama
dont vous allez acheter de l'art et la
lèze la bia d'une marque à l'autre
et si gm allemand les magasins vont
bientôt être fermé d'asie c'est quand tu
veux je j'ai adoré cette émission peut
[ __ ] le bordel comme ça c'est toujours
un plaisir et en plus tout le bordel
mieux le poids
bien alors marié bien la boue va très
bien jacques michel le bouquet à côté
cela